[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيات وانا راويه
العالمي
للهواء اسرار من دون شك
ورومانسيه مثل البحر الواسع
وكلنا لسبب ما بنشعر انه نحن قادرين على
الغوص لاعماقه لحتى نوصل لهذه اللؤلؤه
اللي تسمى الحب لكن للاسف كثير منا بيغرق
اثناء المحاولات
بصراحه بما اني امراه متزوجه اصبحت نوعا
ما بعيده عن حكايه الشخص المناسب او الغير
المناسب من زمن طويل لكن شخص عزيز على
قلبي كان بيحدثني من بضاعه ايام عن حديثه
مع مجموعه من الشباب في العمل وكان موضوع
الحديث هو صعوبه ايجاد شريك حياه هذه
الايام اللي صديقي بانه احدى الحضارات
كانت بتتحدث عن انه كيف محاولاتها
المستمره لايجاد زوج او شريك مناسب دائما
تبوء بالفشل مرارا
وبين ما صرح شاب اخر حسب ما اخبرني صديقي
انه تطبيقات المواعاديه صارت مصدره الوحيد
المتوفره لا تعرف على الجنس الاخر كون
طبعا وقت الفراغ المتوفر له قليل وما
بيسمح له بالتواجد باوصات صحيه بتمكنه من
التعرف لفتاه علها تكون هذه الفتاه هي
المنشده لكن وبعد سنتين من التجارب
ومحاولات اعد فشلت اخر محاوله له
طبعا رحنا نتبادل الحديث انا وصديقي يعني
هذا الموضوع مطولا وما تركته حتى اضطريت
اني اغزو اليوتيوب والجوجل احاول ابحث عن
اجوبه للسؤال اللي ضل يكرره هذا الشخص
لماذا بالرغم من كل المحاولات المتكرره
والجاده والنيه الصافيه كمان تبو
محاولاتنا لايجاد شريك مناسب بالفشل علم
الاجتماع عنده نظرياته في الاجابه على هذا
السؤال وكمان علم النفس لكني وجدت نفسي
اكثر لايجاد الجواب بناء على تجارب
الانسانيه
فحولت اني الاقي قواسم مشتركه همم ما بين
كل هذه النظريات وبنفس الوقت استجمع كل ما
اعرف وكل ما قرات وشاهدت وسمعت وادمج
صافيه هذه الخبره الشخصيه
باجابات العلوم الاخرى
فلقيت انه عمليه البحث عن شريك حياه هي
طبعا لا يخفى على احدنا امر صعب للغايه
وبالنسبه للشباب عامه فبدايه العلاقه عاده
بتكون مليئه بالامان وبالفرح وللاسف كثير
من الاحيان بتنتهي هاي العلاقات بالفشل
لسببنا هؤلاء الشبان بيضلوا دائما مصرين
على تكرار المحاوله وهذا في حد ذاته اكيد
يدعوا للاحترام ولكن يمكن في عوامل كثير
اللي واسباب ايضا اللي بتحول بدون الوصول
لهذا الشريك المنشود والشريك المناسب اكيد
راح احكي مع ضيفتي في وقت لاحق من الحلقه
حول شو هي ممكن تكون الاسباب همم سواء كان
من واقع خبرتي او من واقع خبرتها المهنيه
بهذا المجال ولكن على كل حال احنا تخيلوا
معي لو طلبنا من شاب او شاب انهم يتداونوا
في ورقه كل ما بيتمنوا في شريك حياتهم
بالغالب راح نقرا يمكن اجوبه
على هذا النسق انه اريد شريك او شريك طيبه
وصبوره ويكون مستقل بذاته لكن سهل انه يحب
تكون مثلا هي طويله البال وهادئه لكن
مليئه بالطاقه يكون واثق من نفسه لكن ما
عنده اي مشكله من انه يضحك على نفسه تكون
مثلا انسانه جميله جدا ولكنها متواضعه
يكون شخص مجنون بالحياه لكن يعي تماما ما
يريد ونوعا مسؤول
يمكن الاشخاص بيبينوا انه هن بيعرفوا
بالضبط نوعيه الشخص اللي هنا بدوروا عليه
لكن الشخص اللي بينتهي به المقام جالس
امامنا بيكون يمكن انسان مختلف تماما عن
الوصف اللي احنا كنا بندور عليه والسؤال
هون ليه
الحياه بتعلمنا مع تقدمنا بالعمر انه
البشر ما كانوا ولا راح يكونوا ابدا
مختصرين لفريقين يا اما ابيض صالح يا اما
اسود صالح كل منا بيملك طبعا مواضع ضعف زي
ما بيملك مواضع قوه
على السطح لما بنكون في علاقه حب فاي
نصفين يطفوا هو الامر المتعلق فينا واللي
نوعا ما احنا اللي بنختاره كل انسان هو
تركيبه خاصه ومعقده لما مقابل الشركاء
المحتملين فهؤلاء الاشخاص ياتوا الينا
وهنا كمان بيحملوا في داخلهم او سنه وندوب
من معاركهم السابقه وتجاربهم الحياتيه
السابقه مثل ما احنا بنحمل تماما مع هاي
التوليفه وبالرغم من المحاولات المتكرره
نوجد انفسنا في اغلب الاوقات النساء كيف
انتهينا مع انسان او انسان بتشبه الى حد
كبير جدا الشخص اللي هربنا
علاقتنا معه للتوب ليه عم نكرر نفس
الاخطاء
باعتقادي انه الايجابي يمكن تكمن في دخلنا
بقصد انه لو اردنا معرفت لماذا مهما
حاولنا تغيير طريقه التفكير والنمط
الاختيار بننتهي لنفس النوع اللي بنحاول
انه نهرب منه هو امر نابع من داخلنا وما
بنقدر نعزيه للحظ زي ما بيحلو طبعا لا
كثير من الناس انهم يعلقوه على شماعه حظهم
السيء للحظ ما له اي دخل في هذا الموضوع
تجاربنا هي اللي جعلتنا ما نحن عليه الان
وهي اللي بتاثر على اختياراتنا للشخص اللي
من حاول انه نمضي عمرنا معه
بيقول الكاتب
مؤسس شركه مدرسه الحياويه شركه تعليميه
مقرها المملكه المتحده بتقدم عاده نصائح
لطلابها نصائح حياتيه ودورات علم النفس
وعلاقات انسانيه المهم بيقول اهلا نحن
نبحث دون وعي عمن يضايقنا
وهذا تفسير محاوله بعضنا تعريف شخصين احنا
بنعرفهم نتوقع انهم نعرفهم مع بعضهم
ينجحوا الا انهم يعني احدهم او كلاهم
بيعودوا بيخبرونا انه لم يجدوا الشخصيه
الشخصيه الاخر مثيره للاهتمام بالنسبه لهم
وبيقول الم انه هذا نابع من انه فكرتنا عن
الحب هي مبنيه على شعورنا في لاول مره في
مرحله الطفوله من والدينا هذا الحب ما كان
دائما مكون من غيوم ورديه واقواس قوس قزح
يعني كلياتنا نوعا ما يعني تعرضنا للنوع
من انواع القسوه من والدينا او الشده
وعدده يعني او في بعض الاحيان بيكون هذا
الحب حب الابوين ايضا مخلوط بخيبه الامل
واحيانا بالانكسار واحيانا اخرى بالمحصله
بيكون هناك بعض من المعاناه لكنه اكيد كان
حب عظيم بلا شك وعليه ففي اعماقنا من دون
منوعه احنا بنبحث عن شعور مشابه لما كبرنا
عليه ولما نلتقي بشخص ما بيستخرج واحد او
اكثر من هاي المشاعر السلبيه وحتى لو كان
بيحبنا فاحنا في الغالب ممكن نشعر انه لا
هذا شخص ممل غريب صح طيب خلينا نحكي مع
اهل الاختصاص عن هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع
بعتقد بانه كثير شيق
ويمكن هذا السؤال اللي بيكره همم كثير ناس
بيسالوا هذا السؤال برحب بضيفتي في
الاستوديو سيرين زياده مختصه في ترجم
اللغويه العصبيه والذكاء العاطفي
الاجتماعي اهلا وسهلا فيك يا سيرين معنا
مره ثانيه اهلا وسهلا فيك يا رب ان شاء
الله هيك نظيف قيمه ومعلومات مقيم للناس
اللي عم بسمعوها وكيفنا الممكن من الموضوع
زي ما حكيت كثير شيق تحدي يمكن كثير ناس
بتمر فيه من ناحيه العلاقات اكيد هي
الفكره كلياتها يمكن من طرح هذا السؤال
انه
خلي كل شخص يمكن بيعاني من المشكله اللي
راح نحكي عنها يفكر اكثر ويعمل يعني ينظر
للداخل لانه همم يعني احنا يمكن لنا ايد
في جزء كبير من اي معاناه احنا بنعاني
منها على الاقل على الصعيد النفسي خلينا
نقول طيب ندخل في الموضوع على طول اذا هيك
همم سيرين شو اللي بيخلي يعني انا باحس
انه بموضوع العلاقات والبحث عن الشريك
المناسب
والحصول او همم العثور على همم في عده
تحديات زماننا اللي احنا عايشين فيه اول
شيء انه يعني عم بتطلع حوالي عم بشوف انه
يعني كثير شباب
عم يفشلوا بينهم يلاقوا الشريك المناسب ما
بعرف يمكن متطلبات عصريه
او شروطهم مختلفه
وصابرهم اقل وهمم حتى رغبتهم في التنازل
او همم انهم يعملوا همم قمر زي ما بين قال
همم صارت قلبك كثير بس هاي مشكله على
جانبي يمكن نحكي فيها بحلقات قادمه
المشكله الاخرى بانه بلاحظ بانه او لاحظت
بانه فيه كتير ويمكن كلنا وقعنا فيها
المشكله همم في كثير ناس بتضلوا يكررون
نفس النمط من العلاقات وخصوصا اذا كانت
علاقات يعني فاشله او بتنتهي بالفشل بردوا
بيرجعوا بيبنوا علاقه اخرى مع شخص مشابه
ده ده ماكس تبعت العلاقه هي نفسها ليش هيك
بصير احنا اصلا شو هي همم
يعني اسس الاختيار على اي اساس احنا خصوصا
احنا لسه في بدايه عمرنا بنختار هل هو
بناء على شو شفنا ببيتنا مع عائلتنا
وابونا سواء كانت ايجابيه او سلبيه اوكي
في مقوله كتير بحب احكيها بشكل عام عن
العلاقات انت لا تجذب ما تريد انت تجذب ما
انت عليه يعني كثير بدنا اشياء معينه بدنا
نكون في العلاقه بنقول واحد اثنين ثلاثه
لكن هي النيه بالعقل الواعي بتكون النيه
انا واعيه عليها لكن شو النوايا اللي
بالعقل الباطن من الممكن تكون عكس تماما
ان هي اللي بدي اياها فهيني اللي جواتها
نحن ما بنكون نوعين لاهلها يعني بيكون
برنامج بشتغل لحاله
واعطيكي مثال معين مشان تقدري تربطي
الموضوع بشكل
سهل اكثر
لنفترض اجيت قلت لك انا هلا امم عينوني
الشركه وبدي اتعلم كيف طريقتك لشراء
الملابس
كثير في ناس من ناحيه انهم يعلموني
استراتيجيه اختيار الملابس لانه اختيار
الاشخاص شويه بيكون الموضوع شويه مثلا
همم
بافوت بقيس وخلاص وبروح بشتري همم هل هو
هدف عليهن اللي صار لا في استراتيجيات
داخليا عم بتصير نحن مش معين عليها اول
شيء انت بتقرر انت ايمتى تشتريه كثير او
وقت احنا ما بنكون عارفين امتى بقرا امتى
اشتريها الان محتاج لهذا الشيء ولا لا شو
الدوافع تبعتي للشراء بتوصلي مثلا بتقرري
كيف قررتي اون لاين ولا قررتي همم تروحي
فيسكلي تشتري الموضوع الشيء اللي بدك اياه
كيف قررتنا اي محلات نروح عليهم ولا احنا
بنعمل
لكل المحلات
وهي عم تبحث عن شريك
يعني تقول ما ليس فيها حتى بدون وعي- يعني
هي بتعطي صوره للشريك اللي قدام ها على هو
كيف حابب انه يكون ولكن ليس هو فعلا كما
هو واحد هي واحد والنقطه الثانيه اللي همم
لكلامك مثلا خلاني افكر فيها بانه معنى
ذلك بانه كثير منا ما بنعرف حالنا عن جد
ما بنعرف نحن متى شو بنحبوا شو بنكره عنجد
وهذا الشيء انا برايي يعني تجربتي الشخصيه
على قلبي
قناه
تفكير تكون موافقه مع هذا الشيء يعني
اعطيك مثال ممكن تكوني تقولي انا بحب انه
الشخص يكون صادق باحب الشخص يكون محترم
بدي اياه يكون مثلا
يتواصل معي بطريقه منيحه تمام فانت حطيتي
تدرج قيم معينه لا الكواليتيز اللي بدك
اياها انت كشخص في في هذا الشريك تمام هلا
انت ممكن بدك اشياء ثانيه كثير بس هاي
الاشياء الثانيه ايش في القاعه همم تحت
تحت ما بتكوني واعيه لها فلما تشوفي هذا
الشريك ووفاء يعني توافق مع واحد اثنين
ثلاثه اصبح الشريك المناسب اليك فانا خلاص
شفت هذول اللي اشي وهدا سمير اللي هو
الحلاوه البدايات اعطاني
الاساسيات او الاولويات اللي ببحث فيها في
العلاقه لكن هناك اولويات كثير اكثر في
العلاقه احنا ما بنكون نوعين لاهلها
لما مثلا تمشي العلاقه مده معينه بتصير
تقولي لا لما تروح الستره وتيجي الفكره او
على الاقل هذول الكيماويات اللي بتكون
باول الحب
اه ترجع تفتح
بذوب الثلج وبيبين اللي تحته فانا بصير
اوعى انه لا مش هذا الشيء الي بدي اياه
بالعلاقه فانت بتكوني الارضي خلاص دخلتي
في العلاقه واستثمرتي فيها وقت وعاط
وعواطف ومشاعر فشل اللي بيصير بيصير في
بعض الاشخاص بيصيروا يتنازل ويضحوا كيف او
من الممكن يقنعوا حالهم انه لا هو منيح هو
لا في كثير اشياء منيحه فهمتي كيف يصير
الموضوع من انه انا بقنع حالي عشان انا
خايف اني انا اواجه نفسي اني انا اشتقت لك
عمالها
وبعدين الشخص طبعا بياخذ وقته او ما بياخذ
وقته
[موسيقى]
بنفس الطريقه وبيختاروا نفس النمط ليش هذا
الحكي هل
اذا كان علم النفس بيقول بانه احنا بنتاثر
ببيتنا يعني او علاقه
امنا وابونا مع بعض هي اول
تجربه لنا او اول تعريف احنا شفناه
ولمسناه لشو هو الحب اوك ممكن يكون ايجابي
فبالتالي احنا اذا كان هو شيء ايجابي
وبنطلع عليه من نظره ايجابيه
فهل بنصير ندور
حتى نعيدها التجربه حتى لو كانت مثلا همم
يعني طفله مثلا اهالينا بتعاملوا معنا
بشويه طفله بنصير ندور على حدا شريك
بنتعامل معنا بنفس الطريقه واذا كانت
النظره سلبيه يعني كانت علاقه انه ابونا
مش هالقدم منيحه ومش مش صحيه بنصير ندور
على عكسها برده ممكن يقع بها غلط
وتاثيره على اختياراتنا والمنظومه
العلاقات نقدر
كثير كثير ليش لانه احنا اول
بتحكي همم 12 سنه من حياتنا بتتشكل فيها
ثلاث ارباع هويتنا الذاتيه هويتنا
العاطفيه هويتنا الشخصيه هويتنا التنفيذيه
هويتنا التعبيريه او الابداعيه هويتنا
الاجتماعيه عده هوايه هويات الشكل اللي
جوانا فا نقدر نحكي اامم هلا لو بدي اطلع
على مثلث العلاقه مثلث العلاقه اللي هو
انا وماما وبابا ماما وبابا لما باجيء على
هذه الدنيا شو بيكون بالنسبه لي بكونوا
بالنسبه لي الخالق الله
اصلا
وجودي فبالتالي يتشكل اول شيء اول والهويه
الهويه هل انا موجود هل انا الي قيمه
واهميه لو وجود يعني عشان هيك الطفل
الصغير لما بيبكي
الغيار وكذا بيكون اول احتياج لانه
شعورتي يعني اشعر اني لما اقول اه في حد
موجود يسمعني
هلا هذا الاحتياج بيكبر معانا لما انت
مثلا
اول احتياج ينبغي ان يكون متواجد هو
الشعور بالاستقرار عشان هيك اصلا لما بيجي
الواحد يرتبط مع حدا اول سؤال بساله هل
انت مستقر نفسيين داخليا اذا مش مش مستقر
ما تتوقع الشريك يعطيك هذا الاستقرار او
او يعني
عن عن عن عن
شخص اخر هذه انا بدي نصف الثاني شخص مين
قال انك بدك نصف الثاني انت النصف انت
يمكن هذه الرغب سريرين همم شيء ربنا زرعها
فينا يعني عشان هيك احنا سوشيال قاعده
في الكتاب الكريم وخلقنا لكم من انفسكم
ازواجا
لتسكنوا اليها
برافو
الشعور بالامان السكينه والطمانينه تمام
هلا هذا الاحتياج الشعور بالسكينه
وطمانينه ما بسهر من من ناحيه معينه في
كثير له ابواب بتشعرك بالامان والطمانينه
مع هذا الشخص فان الممكن احنا بننظر من
باب واحد وباقي الابواب ما بنظرها فببلش
ايش تصير في العلاقه عدم الامان خلينا
نرجع لنقطه موضوع انه كيف باثر تربيه
البيت على فشل العالم
اذا صار في شروخ في هذه الهويه احنا بنحكي
عن الطرف اللي هو الطرف الراس في المثلث
العلاقه صار عندي انا شرخ عندي شعور
بالنقص في الاحتياجات اهلي ما كانوا
يسمعوني ما اعطوني الثقه اللي محتاجها
محسسوني باهمتي عواطفي ما كانت يعني
مفهومه من طرفهم عندي احتياج وجعاطفي فصار
في عندي عدم توازن داخلي تشكل جواتي انا
كشخص هويه مشروخه سواء من ناحيه انه نظر
نفسي ماي سيلف ستيم هل وجودي هالقبول عند
الناس
فاذا انشخت هاي الهويه ايش اللي بصير فينا
لنفترض انه شخص معين همم اهله كانوا
ينتقدوه بشكل كبير تمام شو اللي راح يصير
فيه داخليا هيصير عنده صوت ينطقته بشكل
كبير كبير هلا تخيلي انه كل هذه الهوياتي
عباره عن هاله حوالينا وهاي الشروق في
الهويات بتسبب انه انا طاقيه اجذب الناس
اللي من الممكن
يعززه هذا الشيء الموجود جواتي
منطقه حالي كثير هلا ايناس
بنتقدوني بشكل كثير اكثر هذا من ناحيه
الهويه
ما بحب حالي
او ما يعاملني بطريقه
وهذا الشخص الي مفكره انه بيحبني هو فعليا
ما بيحبني هو مجرد مجرد علمني درس كيف
قاعد حالي
فيديو تحت
طب ليه انا ما بحب حالي وما بين انه ببحث
على حدا ينجذب ليه من الخارج لانه انا
حاسه انه انا من الداخل لا استحق اني احب
تربيت فيها صار فيها نوع من شرخ الحب يعني
من الممكن اهلي يحبهم لالي هو حب مسؤوليات
شربتي درستي همم عملتي الواجب
استمد منه
انثى
فاكثير في امهات طاقه بفكروا انه انه ما
تيتا او ماما علمتني انه هيك الحب فبيجوا
على طول اولادهم بهذه الطريقه لكن احنا كل
واحد فينا لما بنولد ما بنولد بنفس
الجينات والدي ان تبعنا على هيك اعباءنا
النفسيه تورث طبعا تورث اكيد عشان هيك
احنا بنفكر انه ال ال ال الصفات معينه
فينا هي عباره عن وراثيه لا هي هذه الصفه
اللي تعلمتها من اهلي غيرت لي الدي ان اي
تبعي عشان هيك بيجي اولادي نفس الديانات
ليه لان البيئه بتاثر على الدي ان تبعنا
يعني
بعد الدراسات
ببعض المجلات بانه يعني حتى من الناحيه
الجسديه تغيير عادات معينه مثلا اكل الاكل
مش صحيح فيه سكريات عالي ممكن انه يغير
عمل الخلايا ودي ان اي تبعها على الاقل
فيها يعني في اطار هذا الجسر ما كنتش اعرف
انه ممكن
عن طريق التعامل ههه
احساسك بانك انت فوق في السماء انه ما في
حدا غيرك في الدنيا وبكون ايش كثير بحب
يعمل علاقات كثير تمام فانتي بهذا الشخص
صار في فشل في العلاقه طلعت من العلاقه شو
طلعتي مكسوره اكثر عندك اكثر وين بدك شو
بدك اكثر
مره ثانيه
وكف وراء كف لحتى تصحي انه المشكله مش
براتك المشكله جوانتي الانسان بيوصل لهذا
يعني اكيد ما في عمر معين
وتتابعي الشخص نفسه وقديما ده قدرته على
تعلم من تجاربه بس امتى اللحظه اللي ممكن
الشخص يعني لانه في ناس بتظلها بتعمل نفس
الاخطاء تكرر نفس انماط العلاقات
يعني ممكن انه يكملوا مع شخص بس لانه كان
في محاولات فاشله كثير قبل هيك والشخص هذا
غير يعني لا يحتمل الفشل مره اخرى
وبيكمل مع انه العلاقه ما فيهاش
امتى بيصحى الواحد امتى بغير
بس الواحد لما بيفهم اكثر اوكي بس حل واحد
لما
زي ما حكيتي في ناس ما بصحوا الا بعد اكمن
فشل في العلاقه بعدين بيصيروا يقولوا
يوقعوا انه طيب الموضوع متكرر معناتهم ليه
انا عم بختار هذا الشخص ليه انا عم بوقع
في علاقات فاشله واني دائما اكثر الاسئله
اللي بيسالوا الناس ليه انا عم بختار
الشخص اللي مش مناسب ليه انا بجذب الاشخاص
الناس الشباب
وفي انه الكاتشب هو له اساس بنجاح العلاقه
فشلها لانه هينا احنا عم نعيش ل2020
بعالم مختلف تم منع العالم العاشو اهلا هل
يعني ذلك انه في علاقات كثير عم تفشل لا
مش شرط هي مجرد انه
نسبه الطلاق
مثلا تاخر سن الزواج في في تغيرات طبعا في
تغيرات لكن مثلا
كيف بدي اسالك اياها المبدا انه زمان
كانوا اهالينا ما عندهم خيارات اكثر
للطلاء وحده الوحده تقعد هل هذا يعني
اكيد فشل صامت اه غير موفق غير موثق ههه
بيقدر يعبر عن نفسه في استقلال اكثر
فبتلاقي عشان هيك عم نشوف الفشل اكثر
صار موفق اكثر واضح لاني اكثر تمام وصار
المجتمع متقبل له اكثر فبالتالي صار في
افصاح عنه
وفرصه البدايه الجديده يعني
فشل العلاقه كمان بيعتمد على عدم
الاستحقاق يعني انا مثلا على فردا عندي
قناعات معينه تحدد استحقاقي وهذا كثير
بنسمعه انا كبرت مين بده يتجوزني وين بدي
الاقي الواحد بنت زي العالم والخلاء همم
وين من الممكن انه همم العلاقات صارت كثير
صعبه فانا بانيت استحقاقات داخليه لصعوبه
حصولي على الشخص المناسب توقعاتي اذا
نزلتها كثير بحيث انه خلص اكيد مش موجوده
كانت العلاقه صعبه بيناتهم
فهنا مثلث التاثير في العلاقه انه من
الممكن ما شفت الحب والرومانسيه بين ماما
وبابا من الممكن كان في مشاكل كثير بين
ماما وبابا من الممكن كان في فشل في
العلاقه انا بلشت ادرك ولما كنت اكبر
فبيصير عندنا منظومه برضه العلاقات
الاجتماعيه يعني تاثير الام والاب بشكل
كتير كتير باثروا على منظومه العلاقات
واختياراتنا على الاقل واحنا صغار
حتى وانت كبيره لها شعوريه
انا عم بضحك لانه احنا يعني مثلا خليني
اقول هيك شيء شخصي نوعا ما انه مثلا انا
واحده من اربعه اطفال او يعني اخواتي احنا
اربعه
كثير مثير للاهتمام هلا بعد ما كبرت وعيت
بطلع على اختياري انا واخوي اللي اصغر مني
بشوي ااا اختيارنا كان فيه له تاثير معين
من الفتره احنا قراب على بعض بالعمر من
الفتره اللي احنا كنا فيها صغار من من كان
اللي له تاثير بحياتنا اكثر بينما اختيار
الاثنين الصغار
معنى ذلك انه اذا كانت علاقه يعني همم
الوالد والوالده سيئه ويقعدون على ذلك انه
علاقاتنا احنا ما يعني فرصها في النجاح
انا انا لست امي وشريكي ليس ابي عشان ما
تكون العلاقه فاشله ينبغي التسامح مع
الاهلي
كيف يعني وعي الاهل يعني اهلي لنفترض انه
كان في مشاكل بيناتهم وحتى طريقه تعاملهم
معي مش الطريقه اللي كنت بدي اياها يكون
برفضها من تسلط تحكم اوفر بروتيكتيف ناس
قلقت وترجم مكان يكون
اذا انا ما تسامحت مع وعي اهلي يعني فهمت
انه هذا الشيء اللي عملوه اللي قدموه
وبناء على وعيهم المشاكل اللي وقعوا فيها
شو الاغلاط اللي غلطوها بدل ما اني احكم
عليها احول الموضوع العبره هي الفكره
بيتهيا لي انه همم
نشوف اهالينا على انهم بني ادمين بيخطفوا
وهذا اللي بيعرفوا وهنعمله الافضل ما
استطاعه بما يملك من معرفه ويمكن معرفتي
انا بهذا العمر اكثر من معرفتهم نظرا
الدنيا تغيرت اصلا وصار الانسان بشكل عام
عنده همم
مخزون من التجارب اكثر من الاجيال السابقه
عنده كمان عكسس لانفورميشن اكثر بكثير من
الاجيال السابقه بس انا انا يعني حتى برضه
شخصيه حسيت انه فعلا لما صرت اطلع على
الوالد والوالده على انهم
بني ادمين زي زيهم بتعلموا بيخطئ وبصيبه
خصوصا اذا اجوا طلعوا من اماكن فيها نوع
من العنف كان فيها مشاكل
كثير كثير في روابط الامان عنا بتزعزع
داخليه
كان عنده مور او طاقه الانوثه فحضر الشاب
اللي بتكون عنده طاقه الانوثه كثير
هيجذب واحده عندها طاقه ذكور اعلى اعلى
[موسيقى]
امراه ممكن تكون متسلطه
تقويهم
هيحب مش ضروري متسلط ومتحكي مع شخصيه قويه
مسؤوله قد حالها
تكون قوام على طاقه الانثى والذكر الفرق
بيناتهم انه ما هي الطاقات التي
ذكور او الانثى الانوثه هي مواد ورحمه
وتعاطف همم حب وسلام
ونقول هذا الشاب مر اكثر الانجاز
والاستقلال اللي عرفته
في الجلد الجديده
لاكبير لابسه طقيه
والدور النمطي للمراه او للرجل
فبيصير انه الدور المراه عم تلعب دور
الذكوره في البيت كمان ما هي اورادي بدها
تثبت نفسها وقوتها وتنافسها مع الذكور
اللي في الشغل فبترجع بالعلاقه العاطفيه
بتثبت هذا الشيء فبيصير في نوع من التنافس
عشان هيك ما بيصير في تنازل وتضحي وتقبل
ليه لانه صار في لخبطه بالطاقات
الطفوله لما الاقي امي هي متحركه
الذكر متسلط في حياتك بقلك جميله
غير انه انا عندي اورادي قناعات من الممكن
خوفت الم من العلاقات فبتلاقيني لا شعوريا
التقديري لذاتي منخفض فمين اللي بجذب
الناس اللي هم بيكونوا ايش تقديرهم لذاتهم
مشوه طبعا بطريقه ثانيه يتكبروا علي هم
اللي يتحكموا فيهم يروح يمين وشمال لانه
انا تقديري
وعم بتقولي بانه مجرد ما توضح هاي الصوره
يوضح تاثير مثلا الطاقه الذكوريه
والمساويه بحياتنا واحنا عم نكبر من خلال
علاقه والدنادتنا ببعض وفينا مجرد ما توضع
هاي الصوره من تصير اكثر قدره على رؤيه
ليش عمالنا بنعمل نفس نفس الاختيارات
الخاطئه يعني عشان اعرف انا ليه عم بختار
مثلا غلط
انا كثير بنصح بهذا التمرين انه تمسكه
علاقتك مع والدتك والدتك علاقه والدتك
والدتك اكتبها كليا وشوف شو النمط اللي عم
بيصير كيف هذا النمط اللي انت عشته من
الممكن يكون انعكاس عن النمط اللي انت عم
بتكرر عندك بعلاقاتك لانه في قصه انت عم
بتعيشها وتحضر لك تعيشها لحتى تتحرك من كل
الطاقات اللي بتخليك متعلق في هذه القصه
لا تتحرر منها وهاي القصه زي ما حكينا من
الممكن هي شروخ في الهويه
اذا انا ما قدرت اني شروخ
رحمه الله نعيد القصه كثير قالي نحن ما
نوصل لهذا الموضوع كتير صعب علينا ليه
لانه احنا بننظر للموضوع بشكل خارجي شو
الي بنحاول نعمله وانا معظم الناس اللي
بشوفهم شو بيعملوا انا انتهت العلاقه كيف
بدي اتخلص من الالم والحزن امم الموضوع مش
هيك بس لازم اتعلم لازم اني ارجع واشوف
ايش اللي خلاني اوقف هيك علاقه ليه دخلت
يعني
انه الواحد ينظر الى الداخل فعليا بصدق
وبدون بتجرد من العواطف وبينوع من التوازن
كمان لانه يعني زي ما بيقولوا فعلا يد
واحده ما بتزقف حتى المشكله
يعني انتبهوا يا جماعه انتبهوا انتبهوا شو
الطاقه تبعتكم عشان تعرفوا هذه الطاقه راح
تفتح
عندي طاقه خوفنا العلاقات هيفتح لي باب
الخوف عشان عائشه
كان فيه وانا عم بكبر حالات وفاه مفاجاه
هذا هاجس عندي لهلا وخوف اني افقد من احب
بشكل مفاجاه بدون اي مقدمات ولا مع انه
الموت هو جزء من الحياه وهو لازم نقبل فيه
بس انا مثلا بهذا الخوف هذا بس على سبيل
المثال كيف الواحد بيقدر يتخلص من شيء مثل
هيك يعني
انا عندي مشكله في الخاص فباجي بانظف
الجسدي بنسميها الذاكره الجسديه الذاكره
الجسديه تبعتنا ادركت موت تمام فهي
الذاكره موجوده في جسدنا وموجوده في
عواطفنا وموجوده في افكارنا فاذا انا ما
نظفت هاي الذاكره حد تظل هذه الذاكره
تسيطر عليه كيف ننظف هاي الذاكره في
تمارين تنظيف
الطاقه او تمارين من خلال البرمجه
على فكره بحر اخر لازم ندخل لهم في يوم
اخر يعني لانه ما تصالحت مع هاي الفكره من
الممكن تعلق او خوفي من الموت يظهر في
اشياء ثانيه مختلفه همم
الخوف ما هو له ابواب مختلف خوف من الفشل
خوف من اني انا مثلا انتصل خوف من انه
اولادي ما يكونوا زي يتربوا زي ما بدي
فبصير عندك ابواب ثانيه تنفتح للخوف
بتقول دكتوره تعلم نفسه
خلال 40 سنه من عملها مع العزاب والازواج
بتعتقد انها اخيرا فهمت
غلط
انه قد لا يعجبكم تحليلي لكن اذا ملكته من
الجراه
فممكن انكم تصبحوا اكثر نجاح في اختيار
شريك الحياه مناسب لكم لذلك
نوع من الصبغه العمليه
لطريقه ايجاد هذا الشريك همم ما بعرف هي
الاسئله اكيد راح اعرضها عليكم متابعي
القناه
انه في علاقتكم او علاقتكم السابقه هل كان
الشخص في نهايه العلاقه كما توقعتم ان
يكون في بدايتها هذا هو السؤال الاول
السؤال الثاني بيقول هل تشعرون انكم غالبا
ما تكونون منجذبين لاشخاص لا يمكنكم
الوصول اليهم لاي سبب من الاسباب ثلاثه هل
الخصال التي تتمنون ان تكون في شريك
حياتكم هي خصال ستبقى في لسنين طويله يعني
مثلا وسامي اذا كانت
يعني الجمال لا يدوم والشكل لا يدوم
اربعه برايكم هل من الضروري انه يكون شريك
حياتكم مثير لاهتمام الاخرين بالنسبه لكم
خمسه هل الشخص الي ببالكم الان هو في
متناولكم او ضمن محيطكم
وسته برايكم هل انتم واقعيين وبتملكوا ما
يجب تقديمه للشخص اللي انتم بتريدوه وسبعه
على الاختياراتكم نابعه من الرومانسيه في
داخلكم من الواقعيه
كوثر بتقول انه اذا اجبته بلا على الاسئله
رقم واحد وثلاثه وخمسه وسته واجبت بنعم
على الاسئله رقم اثنين واربعه وسبعه اذا
في الغالب انتم لن تجدوا الشريك المناسب
في بحثكم هذا لا طب يعني بدنا نعطي امل
للمشاهدين السبب بحسب هو انه الجنس البشري
عامه مكون من تجار او هكذا تقول نحن
مبرمجون لعمل مختلفه انواع الصفقات بيننا
وبين بعض وافضل انواع الصفقات طبعا هي
اللي بتكون مربحه لكل الطرفين بالطبع
احيانا بتكون هاي هي النتيجه ولكن غالبا
للاسف هذه النتيجه ما بتكون هي الحقيقه
والسبب في ذلك هو انه اغلبنا بظن انه قادر
على اتمام صفقه ونحنوب فعليا غير قادرين
حقيقه على فعل ذلك فمثلا بتحاول انه
صوره بتقول هناك من تتخيل انه لديها
الكثير لا تعطيه اذا ما اعطاها شريك الوقت
الكافي وبذلك فهي بتفترض انه الشخص لابد
وان يؤمن بها الفكره منذ البدايه وانه
يقرر الاستثمار فيها كشخص زي ما مثلا هناك
شخص اخر بعيش في بلدنا او مجتمع ماء بحيث
كانت شعبيته بين الجنس الاخر عاليه جدا
ولكن بتغيير الموقع بتتغير الاحوال لكن
هذا الشخص بيفشل برؤيه المساله من هذه
الزاويه وفي احيان كثيره محيطنا اللي
بنعيشه ممكن انه يغشنا فعلا وان كان عم
تطيب قلب يعني فاصدقائنا او عائلتنا ممكن
تنمي فينا شعور بالثقه هو في الحقيقه اكبر
منه لذلك بيتعجب بعض كيف انه الشخص اللي
نريده عاجز عن رؤيه قيمتنا الحقيقيه ايضا
هناك اسباب اخرى مثل البحث عن الشريف في
الاماكن الخاطئه او في التوقيت الخاطئ وهي
نقطه كثير مهمه انا بحس انه بالفعل يمكن
في هذا الزمن زمن السوشيال ميديا وعصر
السرعه
الاماكن اللي احنا ممكن نقابل فيها
شركاءنا المحتملين صارت همم اكثرها اون
لاين مثلا الدايتنج ابس او تطبيقات
المواعده واللي ما باعتقد بانها بيئه صحيه
اصلا لا لا البحث عن شريك او حتى ايجاد
شريك من خلالها الا من قبل ما نداريه يعني
على كل حال من المنطقي انه انقر بسهوله
انحراف عن المسار الصحيح في رحله البحث عن
الشريك المناسب
للمساعده في القاء الضوء على هذه المساله
همم حبيت اعطيكم بعض الامثل اللي بتسبب
هذا النوع من الانحراف لا حتى نحاول
تجنبها وهذا طبعا من واقع همم بحث همم
يعني بعض الدراسات بتتحدث عن انه الشكل او
التركيز على الشكل على حساب المضمون همم
هو احد الاسباب التي تقف عائق امام ايجاد
الشخص المناسب والشريك المناسب من الطبيعي
الاعتراف بانه الجمال او الوسام خصوصا هلا
في زمن السوشيال ميديا هو امر مهم توفره
في الشريك المحتمل واهتمامنا بمظهرنا
الخارجي هو امر ضروري لكن في ما يتعلق
بموضوع الشكل خلينا نعترف انه شكل هو هبه
من رب العالمين سبحانه وتعالى هو انعم على
بعض من خلق همم في هذا الشكل الجذاب
والجميل اكثر من غيرهم
عشانك من وجد انه من لا يملك رصيد كبير من
الوسامه او الجمال بركز على الاهتمام او
بيهتم اكثر
بتطوير نواحي اخرى في لايمانه انه هي
الخصال هي اهم من المظهر الخارجي لكن
للشخص المقابل المهتم فقط بالجمال يمكن ما
يملك احيانا الوقت الكافي لحتى همم يعرفنا
اكثر ويرى هذا الجمال الداخلي او هذه
الشخصيه البراقه لانه يمكن هذا الشخص انزل
لهم من حساباتهم انزل الشخص اللي ليس على
القدر الكافي من الجمال من حساباته ببدايه
العلاقه ولان هناك عدد في الدنيا كما في
الاخره
كلالشخصين يعني سواء كانت المهتمه
بالوسامه فقط او الشخص الاخر المهتم
بالجمال الداخلي مثلا اللي بيهتم بالوسامه
والجمال اكثر اكيد راح يعني بلحظه من
اللحظات انه الجمال بشكل الوقت ومع مرور
السنين ممكن يفقد هذه الدعامه الاساسيه هي
اللي بدات العلاقه عليها شو بكون الحل هيك
حاله ايضا الشخص اللي ارتبط بفتاه مثلا
بسبب شكلها الجميل واللي مثلا ممكن يكون
ثمانيه من عشره فهذا الشخص دوما راح تطير
نظراته كل ما راى واحده اجمل تمثلي يمكن
10 من 10
وفي هاي الحاله ما على الشريكه وقتها الا
العيش في خوف دائما هروب شريكها بحثا عن
من هي اكثر جمالا وعليه فان هذا المعيار
عاجلا لما اجلا راح يفشل العلاقه احد
الاسباب الاخرى من واقع البحث همم لقيتها
بانه تفادي الشريك الثقيل اصبح شيء مهم
وهن ما بتحدث عن الوزن طبعا ولكن باتحدث
عن فكره انه احنا احيانا من قابل من جذب
اليهم بالجنون ما ان تبدا مرحله التعرف
على بعض حتى نتفاجا بين هذا الشخص يمكن
اتانا باثقاله يعني ممكن يكون مطلق او
ارمله او يكون فيه له اولاد سابقه ويكون
وضعوا المادي ضعيف او ممكن له عنده التزام
تجاه اسرته احيانا بكون الشخص صاحب مهنه
غير عاديه بيعمل ساعات مختلفه عن الدارج
او دائم السفر او مثلا شريكه لديها مشكله
صحيه الى اخره اذا كنت من من يهربون من
هذا النوع من العلاقات فانت لم تصبر حتى
تكتشف شخصيه الشريك الحقيقيه اللي ممكن
تكون رائعه فيما لو اعطيت العلاقه ماساحه
كافيه فقط يمكن احيانا بالرغم من المشاكل
الظاهره على السطح ممكن تكون او يكون هذا
الانسان اجمل واروع بكثير ممن لا يملكون
هذا النوع من التحديات فعليه احد الاسباب
الاخرى الخلط ما بين النجاح المادي وغنى
الشخص هاي طبعا صفه وجدت عند الاناث من
فجر التاريخ للاسف قديما كان على المراه
انها تستخدم كل الاسلحه الانثويه لحتى
تحضى بزوج قادر على حمايتها واطعامها
واطعام اولادها لكن طبعا الزمن تغير
واليوم النساء في سوق العمل زي الرجال وما
عاد من الضروري انه الرجل يعيل بيته بشكل
كامل لكن ما زال هناك في امن النساء تتبع
هذا التفكير القديم واللي بصراحه انا
بلاقيه مضحك يعني في بعض الاحيان لانه
اصبحنا في زمن انقلبت في الايات فبات هناك
في ان الرجال الان كمان بيبحثوا عن المراه
الغنيه حتى تسهل حياتهم
وهون بحب اقول للاثنين انه في بعض الاحيان
يعني هذا الغنى اللي بتكون همم يعني
الاناث او حتى الرجال بيبحثوا عنه وهو
بيكون همم غنى وراثي وغالبا ما بيكون من
تربى بحبوحه ماديه رجل كان او امراه
بيكونوا نوعا ما منفصلين عن الواقع وضعفاء
في مواجهه مشاكل الحياه وهذا بيجعل
الشريكه او الشريك اقل قوه من مدراءهم من
دخلوا معترك الحياه في وقته اما النوع
الثاني فهو عاده بيكون الغناء اللي يعني
اللي بتصنعوا المراه او جون بانفسهم
وهؤلاء بيكونوا حققوا النجاح بالعمل الجاد
والعمل الدؤوب
فالمشكله عاده عند اغلبهم بتكون انه كلهم
مدمنين عمل بيكونوا وهذا دائما ما باثر
سلبا على حياتهم الشخصيه
فعزيزه المراه وعزيزه الرجل ممكن تمنعك
هاي العلاقه حساب بنكي كبير لكنها ايضا
راح تعطيك حساب عاطفي صغير جدا فكروا
ماليا اذا ما كان هذا معياركم
في سبب اخر اللي هو بيكون الشخص او الشريك
فيه وبعض العيوب اللي احنا صعب انه نتعايش
معها ولكن دائما بنفكر باسلوب ساغير لاحقا
او ساغيرها لاحقا طبعا مرايه الحب عمياء
وهي مقوله رددها اجدادنا من عقود طويله
لكنها تصدق وصدت في وجه الزمن فاجمل ما في
العلاقات كما يقال البدايات بحيث نكون
احنا دائما مسحورين بهذا الشعور وبالحب
الجارف ومع الوقت بنصير اكثر قدره على
رؤيه ما لا نحب من خصال في شركائنا
والجميع بظن انه لا باس مع الوقت راح
يتغير للاسف هون هو بالفعل مربوط الفرس
لانه لم اسمع بصراحه كثير من الازواج
بيرددوا والله كان فيها خصله كذا وانا لم
اكن احبها ولكنها غيرتها او امراه مثلا
بتقول زوجي كذا وكذا لكني تمكنت من تغييره
خليني اقولها بصراحه
تغييرنا لغيرنا يكاد يكون اقرب للمستحيل
وسبيل التغيير الوحيد هو انه كل شخص يغير
نفسه لانه بحب شريكته او شريكه لكن ما
يضحك على نفسه فانت ما راح تغيرها وهي لن
تغيرك المشاكل راح تظهر فجاه مع الاوقات
الصعبه بحيث حبل الصبر راح يكون قصير وهاي
الخصله اللي ما كنت انت تحبها في البدايات
لكنك تغضيت عنها راح تنفجر في وجهك عند
اول مشكله حقيقيه راح تظهر في حياتكم عشان
هيك من الاسلم هو النظر لهذه الخصال من
البدايه والجزم بانه هاي الخصله في حال لم
تتغير انت قادر على التعايش معها لكن اذا
ما شعرت انك لن تستطيع انك تتعايش معها من
الاسلم انهاء العلاقه في بدايهتها الحديث
لا يمل نهائيا بس حابه قبل ما ننهي اتحدث
عن وذكرناها في البدايه بانه همم فعلا
يعني في مشكله بعلاقات اليوم او على الاقل
من يعني هذا الظاهر احنا قلنا او كنت عم
تذكري بانه علاقات الماضيه والاجيال
السابقه كان فيها مشاكل كثير واسلمت تكون
موثقه كانت مشاكل صامته هلا صار في لها
صوت وصار في لها صوت مسموع
مع هيك انا بحس بانه في تغير بهذا الجيل
اللي هلا صاعد همم في تغيرات ايجابيه وفي
تغيرات سلبيه بحس انه انه صار على الاقل
صبر واقل رغبه واستعداد للتنازل او همم زي
ما بيقولوا يلاقي الشخص الاخر في منتصف
الطريق صار في تركيز على هذا رايي الخاص
يعني حابه اسمع رايك همم في تركيز كثير
على شكل الخارجي على حساب المضمون والشكل
الداخلي وصار فيه خلط ما بين مثلا ال- ال-
النجاح المادي والغنى الحقيقي لهذا الشخص
وبعدين صر شيء هيك سريع وخفيف حاجه خفيف
وضحك
حدا ثقيل
حدا الناس تحسدنا عليه ويطلعوا انه يشوفوا
معقول
لك يعني اكيد هلا طبيعه الحياه والمتطلبات
الحياه كثير اختلفت عن الاجيال القديمه
همم طريقه التربيه
المدارس اختلفت انت عم تحكي عن طبيعه همم
الامور اللي احنا عم نتفاعل معها الانفتاح
هذا اللي عم بنشوفه همم بتسمعي قصص بتشوفي
تجارب ناس ثانيين فكل هذه الامور بتلعب
دور في تركيباتنا والطاقه تبعتنا طريقه
تفكيره طريقه نظرتنا الامور
هل هذا كان في مصلحتنا اوضتنا اكيد انا
دائما باقول اي شيء اللي هو فوائد واي شيء
له سلبي
كيف نستخدم هاي الامور بطريقه
انفتاح السوشيال ميديا مثلا واحد من
العوارض او الاشياء اللي هي صارت الناس
تلاقي سهوله اتعرف على واحد وخلص
عامله مشكله على فكره للاسف كمان بطل في
اماكن طبيعيه صحيه الناس تقابل فيها يعني
كله اون لاين بتصير تتصرف الوحده الواحد
وكل اللي بده سريع وما عجبتك خلص بلوك يلا
بعد بكره مع السلامه
بتلاقي الشخص الطرف الثاني انا بعتقد بحس
انه الشباب هلا يعني مثلا الشباب ذكور
بدهم همم
ملكات جمال
متناقضه يعني سواء كان ذكور ام عنا ناس
الشريك بدي اياها تكون زي القمر ولكن
متواضعه هي بدها اياه هو بدها اياها تكون
مثلا سوبر مان
متناقضه والسوشيال ميديا خلى هذا التناقض
يعني سماء
التناقض مش احنا هذا التناقض انه احنا
عندنا اشياء واشياء ثانيه بنشوف المجتمع
بده اياها فصفا انه انا عم باقلد عرفتيه
وبطلت عارفه مين انا وشو بدي بالنهايه
التي لا تموت لصلاه او بعيدا نوعا ما عن
لما نشوفه عن السوشال ميديا لا مضبوط هلا
يعني همم بالنهايه بصفه انه الموضوع العمق
في الطعامق في العلاقه عرفت كيف وفهم نفسي
اولا زي ما حكيت حكيت انه في البدايه انا
لازم افهم نفسي
الاشياء اللي جايه ادخلها في العلاقه لانه
اذا جاء انا ادخل على العلاقه في همم
اشياء مثلا ممكن همم فيها نقاط تحتاج
لتطوير نفسي بالنهايه الطرف الثاني للحيصه
هل هو شخص هيكون يعزز الامور اللي انا
رافضها جوه نفسي ومن الممكن المشاكل اللي
انا بعيشها او الصراعات الداخليه التحديات
الداخليه
حال التوازن دائما لا لكن الاساسي التوازن
يكون ان الحب عندي مش مشوه والحب اول شيء
نستمد الحب اللي انا عايشته ولا نظرتي
وفكرتي عن الحب غير مشوقه الحب بيني وبين
نفسي علاقتي مع نفسي وعلاقتي مع الله
لانه اذا انا عم بدور على الحب مراتي من
الناس انت في حاله احتياج عم تشحد الحب
الناس هتعطيك حب مزيف
حب ليس حقيقي وانما حب مشروط انت لما
بتعملي اللي بدي اياها على نفس الشيء اللي
هو الحب المزيف او المشروط اللي اتعلمناه
ممكن بعض الاهل اللي هو برافو عليك اذا
عملت شيء منيح ومش برافو عليك
انت بتفكري هذا هو الحب لكن الحب عمرك
وكلام جميل كثير على فكره ولكن بحس انه
يستهلك ناس معنا
برده كمان مش حلو انه احنا نفكر حالنا
اكبر بكثير من ما نحن فعلا
اكيد هلا شوفي يعني مبدا حتى مبدا العلاقه
لما نطلع من علاقه احنا بنعتبرها مصدر
لانكسارنا مصدر لتحطينا بدل ما اني
اعتبرها انه مصدر لاني اكبر منها لها مصدر
اني اشوف وين الاشياء اللي انا من الممكن
الفجوات اللي كانت موجوده جواتي ولا
خليتني العلاقه حتى انه تريفلك على موضوع
الطرف الثاني ايش الامور اللي كنت انا
مثلا عم بغض الطرف عنها وعامله نفسي مش
شايفها وبضحك على حالي وبعدين ايش اكتشفت
اني انا برفضها ومش قادره اتحملها
حبيبي او الشخص اللي معه في العلاقه عصبي
كثير
اتعامل معه
قبل ما اقولها كيف تتعامل معها هل او شاب
مثلا بيجي يقول لي هذا السؤال هل انت قادر
تتحمل عصبيت هذا الشخص 20 سنه 30 سنه
40 سنه يمكن هو بوهجه الحب راح يقول لك اه
اه بس هو مش راح يقدر بس على الاقل انا
برمي هذا السؤال تعالي خليك واقعي لانه
هذا الحب الحب مش حب هو المجرد اني انا
الاقي شخص واو عرفت يحرك فيها الكيميائيه
الحب
اهتمام اخلاقيات عرفتي كيف هذا الشخص
بقدمني كيف هذا الشخص تعطيني ايمان
المشكله ان احنا ما بنت عمك بهاي الامور
بنكون ايش داخلين في العلاقه انه بدنا
نطلع نسهر شو بدنا نعمل
موجودين مع بعض على الحلوه بس مش هالمره
المهم كثير انه دايما اني ابدا ما ادخل اي
علاقه اسال نفسي انا جاي من ايام نقطه
انطقي هل انا طالع من طلقه من منطقه هروب
من الالم
ولا جاي من منطقه وفره مزيد للحب النفسيه
كل شخص بيدخل حياتنا وهو بيملائنا بالاشيء
الموجودين احنا موجودين عندي الم وعن بهرب
منه مشاكل علاقات قديمه صدمات عم بهرب
منها وبدي انساها بحب شخص ثاني او مثلا
عندي احتياجات صدقيني هذا الشخص اللي
هيدخل في حياتك هيكون او حياتك هيكون يعزز
الهروب
واذا امتلات وفره اللي هو على الاقل انت
سعيد مستقر حاس حالك ناجح حاسس نفسك
من المشاكل والتحديات وكل ذلك ولكن بتكون
عندك ادوات بتخليك اقوى في مواجهتها صح
همم اذا كنت فعلا جاي من
ساعتين بالضبط
سيرين لا يملك عنجد لا يملى الحديث معك هو
اكيد راح يكون في لنا لقاءات الثانيه
بموضوعات هيك يعني بندخل فيها بعمق
وبتمسنا جميعا سواء كان من تجربه شخصيه
لكل واحد ما لقينا او حتى تجارب احنا
عيشناها وشفناها بشكرك جزيل الشكر سيرين
على وجودك معنا في كلام منطقي بنشوفك عن
قريب ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يا رب وشكرا
كثير للصداعتي وان شاء الله اشوفكم دائما
على خير في ختام حلقتنا
لماذا نختار الشخص الخطا او لماذا نقع في
دوامه اختيار نفس الشخصيه لكن باشكال
مختلفه فهذا له يمكن مئات الاسباب
البعد منا تعب من الرفض فبيركض باتجاه اول
شخص بجده امامه مستعد لقبوله او يمكن في
انسانه لا تريد انها تكون وحيده في حياتها
او يمكن بتشعر بضغط الاهل او المجتمع او
يمكن في انسان اخر متمسك بشريكه بالرغم من
ايمان وانه الامور لا تسير في الاتجاه
الصحيح لكنه يخاف من فكره اذيتها
كلها اسباب تبدو منطقيه للوهل الاولى لكن
نتائج العلاقه مع شخص الخطا وحسابها راح
يكون اكثر ضرر من المضيف في طريق مسدود كل
رجل او امراه له الحق انه يعشق وانه يعشق
كلنا انا حق اساسي بل انسان نكون معه من
يشعر بقيمتنا من يؤكد لنا انه في كل فرصه
احنا مهمين في حياتهم ولا يمكن الاستغناء
عنه واخيرا بحب اني اختم باقتباس لشمس
الدين التبريزي لما قال الامان اعلى منزله
من الحب فلا تقترب حين تنبهر اقترب فقط
حين تطمئن
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيات وانا راويه
العالمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما بامان باذن
الله
[موسيقى]